hey leute ich freue mich dass ihr euch
dieses etwas andere video anschauen
wollt ich redet nicht lange drumherum
ich habe mich rassistisch verhalten und
möchte jetzt dafür geradestehen aber
worum geht es in einem wald test video
von vor zwei jahren haben mein freund
und ich einen südostasiatischen akzent
nachgespielt nachgeäfft könnte man eher
sagen wir haben schon in dem moment
gemerkt dass es nicht korrekt ist haben
noch gesagt ja das ist ja races und dann
habe ich so hochgeladen ich weiß nicht
warum ich dachte dass es damals in
ordnung wäre beziehungsweise ist unsere
gesellschaft in den letzten zwei jahren
aber auch schon zum glück davor in einem
wandel der so wichtig ist bewegungen wie
black lace meter oder stop action held
schicken unsere aufmerksamkeit auf ein
problem was einfach in unserer
zivilisierten welt existiert und wir
werden dem thema rassismus gegenüber
sensibler und hören den betroffenen zu
weshalb wollte ich diese situation nicht
weg ignorieren als ich einen tick tock
gesehen habe was mein verhalten also
genau diese stelle kritisiert hat das
tik tok ging die ral viele leute haben
es gesehen und haben mich dafür
kritisiert
zuerst habe ich mich unter diesen tick
tock video in den kommentaren
entschuldigt das schien mir aber für so
eine ernste angelegenheit zu wenig
deshalb habe ich noch ein eigenes tik
tok hochgeladen in dem ich mich bei der
asiatischen community und besonders noch
bei high entschuldigt habe freies der
verfasser dieses tecdax gewesen und ich
habe ihn in meinem video eingeladen über
diese ganze geschichte und über seine
erfahrungen zu sprechen er hat ja gesagt
und deswegen gibt es heute ein interview
was ich euch zeigen möchte und ich
möchte noch mal kurz sagen diese ganze
situation war zwar sehr unangenehm aber
ich bin so froh dass ich diese erfahrung
jetzt doch gemacht habe denn ich hab
gedacht man kann sich ja selber nicht
rassistisch verhalten wenn man es nicht
böse meint oder wenn man eigentlich ein
guter mensch ist aber ich weiß es heute
zum glück besser in den letzten wochen
konnte ich so viel mehr über das thema
rassismus dazulernen und ich möchte
jetzt hier nicht mein image aufpolieren
oder euch mit erhobenen zeigefinger
irgendwas erzählen ich glaube wenn man
fehler macht sollte man dafür
geradestehen und ich möchte aus diesem
fehler lernen und hoffen vielleicht dass
ein paar von hochwasser zu lernen können
hi hat noch den lieben dich dazu
eingeladen und es würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr euch jetzt das interview
anschaut eine sache noch wir sind auch
wenn wir auf dem bildschirm sind sind
wir einfach alle echte menschen und wenn
ihr mit einer stelle oder einer meinung
nicht d'accord seid dann formuliert dass
bitte höflich nett und konstruktiv ich
bin nicht markus lanz das ist mein
erstes interview trotzdem wünsche ich
euch viel spaß und gute erkenntnisse und
let's go bin heute hier zusammen mit 3
sie haben sich bereit erklärt mit mir
ein interview zu machen und ja über die
ganze sache sprechen die gerade schon im
intro gehört habt und ich würde mit
einer ganz klassischen frage starten und
zwar wie habt ihr in eurem leben
rassismus erfahren also gibt es
geschichten die ihr teilen möchte mal
auf das ein was das ganze ausgelöst hat
also da hast du dein feind sich über
basierte lustig gemacht hat das ist ein
teils alltagsrassismus das bild im
kindergarten schon wo leute welche
spiele spielen wie ich bin chinesen
jetzt bin ich japaner jetzt bin ich
koreaner und da habe ich realisiert da
war es einfach nur ein spiel für mich
später habe ich dann gemerkt ein kinder
das zu mir gemacht haben aber um mir zu
sagen du wirst weniger als im
kindergarten mal das erst mal nur ein
spiel aber später hat es dann angefangen
bedeutung zu bekommen und da habe ich
dann ja was ist muss wahrgenommen und
dann halt auch durch sowas wie akzente
nachmachen hat es dann bei mir die
auswirkungen gehabt dass ich nicht meine
sprache gestimmt habe langsam stück für
stück meine kultur verloren habe und
jetzt habe ich einen jahr bin ich da und
verbunden mit einer kultur und bin
gerade dabei meine sprache zurückzuholen
bist du schon sagen dass leute
absichtlich versucht haben dich zu
verletzen im spät also vielleicht im
garten noch nicht aber später war es
dann wirklich ich suche mir irgendwas
aus was an dir dich am meisten verletzen
im kindergarten weil es wahrscheinlich
seine mitläufer sache dann spielt man
dass andere kinder spielen ich weiß auch
nicht wo das im kindergarten anfängt ob
sie wird die spiele von der wachsenden
erzieherin haben oder so da habe ich es
wollte ich gemerkt in der grundschule
hat ist eine langsam angefahren wo ich
dann das verständnis dafür bekommen hat
dass sich asiate bin asiatisch kinder
oder nichteuropäische länder den ist
erstmal nicht bewusst dass die halt
anders sind vielleicht wissen die dass
sie anders aussehen aber dieses
anderssein das kriegen sie erst mit wenn
die wegen dem anderssein auf anders
behandelt werden und dieses anderes
anders behandelt werden das kam dann
doch in der schule das mit wo sie sich
dann sachen ausgesucht haben deswegen
wegen anders behandeln und das sind dann
halt wirklich die äußeren merkmale oder
die sprache wofür man sich da noch
schämt je nachdem wie sich gar nicht
machen ja bei mir es ist also ist vor
kurzem das was passiert ich weiß jetzt
was mitbekommen hast aber ich habe immer
mehr namen gesprochen tja da gibs halt
einfach darum dass mich angerufen hat
von auto und wenn man ja schon so eine
message oder so eine nachricht von o2
oder so bekommt man eh schon gelernt und
dann keinen bock drauf hat weil man
denkt die wollen einfach verkaufen und
das einzige was ich höre ist ja spreche
ich mit doktor das war erstmal das erste
mal schon sofort getriggert einem langen
tag weiß sondern nennt mich jemand
gleich da so das ist für mich eine
völlig absurde
aussprache von meinem namen wir leben
hier in deutschland und selbst wenn du
das deutsch aussprechen würde ist wer
als nicht ganz sondern eben doch und das
ist offene variante die ich im
akzeptiert für mich und ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass jeder wirklich reich wenn
man dann wenn man meinen namen
ausspricht also so wird ausgesprochen
hab genau richtig und lange zeit wollte
es auch gar nicht so haben ich wollte
immer durch ausgesprochen werden eben
wie die deutsche variante noch damit es
einfacher ist und was daraufhin halt kam
waren einfach und briefen shitstorm also
ein rassistischer shitstorm mit
morddrohungen
gewaltandrohungen und so weiter ich
glaube einfach dass so viele leute
dieses bild von asiaten im kopf haben
also fragen von station zu station dass
wir unterwürfig sind dass wir nicht
unsere mit aufmachen und graf da sind
und nicken so kennt man das ja auch die
asiaten werden einfach als vorzeige
migrantin nannten oben herrscht ja
einfach andere migranten dann runter zu
machen genau und wenn jemand wie ich mal
seinen mund aufmacht und sagt hey das
und das finde ich nicht gut oder das
nervt mich dass jetzt sofort so was
würdest du auch sagen es man kennt ja
diese klassischen vorurteile die man ja
eigentlich immer als kompliment gesehen
hat gern seid ihr alle gut in material
sie hatten oder das ist irgendwo her
dann auch schon beleidigend oder setze
erstmal komisch vor kräftig dass das
stereotype auf dich das hat auch alles
seinen ursprung im vorzeige begrenzenden
mieters oder als auf englisch wollen
meint himmel das beschreibt ziemlich
also die stereotype über ostasiaten dass
wir halt so fleißig sondern erst mal
wurde deshalb wieder erwähnt hat benutzt
um andere migranten runter zu machen um
den zu sagen es gibt doch
gleichberechtigung heutzutage ihr spaß
etwas zu fest ob die abmahnung und
gleichzeitig wird es auch benutzt um
unsere erfahrungen abzusprechen wie zum
beispiel hatte ich meiner schule am
ersten tag es war so mein probetag aber
indirekt das war so eine schlechte
erfahrung dass ich mich in bern musste
leute habe ich um single komische fragen
gestellt in der pause und ich habe da
eine mädchen costa aus der hand gelegt
hat sagt die hat halt das
weißt du
dann habe ich eine e-mail phase gekommen
weil ich mich schlecht benommen habe
also meine mutter hat schießen mit dem
deutschen mann verheiratet er sich ja
nicht von rassismus betroffen ist
jedenfalls hat er dieses migranten
mieters oder vorträgen creditors benutzt
gegen meine erfahrung in dem er gesagt
hat nein es gibt doch keinen rassismus
gegen asiaten gesetzte li fleißig alles
hat seine doppelseite erstmal der
druckdaten dass die migranten
gegenseitig ausgespielt werden dass
andere gesagt hat es gibt auch
gleichberechtigt die asiaten an aber
dann auch mal zu sagen ihr werdet mich
ungerecht behandelt
ich finde das irgendwie gerade total
kann ich meine also beispiel was sogar
gebracht hast mit alle asiaten sind ja
gut in mathe das ist so ein typisches
beispiel von positiven rassismus ich
meinen namen kompliment weil gut der
matte sein ist ja nicht schlecht ist
aber grundsätzlich
stadt führt damit die ideologie dass
rassismus an dem du sax ok oder sieht
asiatisch aus und dementsprechend kann
der was oder kann etwas nicht wollen wir
vielleicht mal gleich schon in diesen
alltagsrassismus reingehen der ja nie
böse gemeint ist und es sind ja nur die
bösen menschen die das mal muss man erst
mal das verständnis dafür haben dass so
was wie ich bin kein rassist das gibt's
erstmal nicht wir werden alle einem
rassistischen system erzogen waren sich
nie was niemanden ab wenn die sagen ich
bin kein rassist ich möchte lieber haben
ich versuche mich gegen rassismus
einzusetzen und betroffenen zuzuhören
das macht mehr sinn als direkt von
vornherein zu sagen das kann nicht sein
ich bringe doch keine leute und ich bin
kein nazi das sind so schlecht menschen
im endeffekt wissen alle was ist dass es
das gespräch oder das fazit was ich mit
vielen dann haben wenn ich über
rassismus reden und da lassen dieses
dann auch aber ich finde dass da
anfangen einzusehen dass weder
rassistisch ist das der erste schritt wo
man dann gegen rassismus folgen kann wie
willst du hast das machst du nicht mal
siehst dass du was das spiel nicht mal
bemerkt dass wir dann so ein system
aufbauen ja komm jetzt im happyland
jetzt wie die betrachteten entlastung
sagt van der vaart ja das happyland ist
ja von kuka roboter formuliert in excel
drayson und das ist so der platz wo
weiße leute drin leben und da gibt es
eigentlich gar kein rassismus der hat
1945 aufgehört keiner redet mehr darüber
weil das angenehmer ist sich nicht damit
zu befassen und dann lebt man ganz schön
im happyland aber es ist halt nicht die
echte welt es ist halt wie so ein fake
welt die man nicht wir können ja genau
und man lebt ja auch eigentlich lebt man
ja auch mal in seiner kleinen babbel da
ist halt die frage irgendwie kriegt man
leute aus dem happyland raus und ich
habe das gefühl nach dem was mir
passiert ist oder setzt mich in dieser
rolle rein stecken zu wollen das habe
ich auf jeden fall aus dem happyland
rausgeholt und dass ich dieses buch exit
races man dann auch mal angefangen hab
anzuhören das gibt es auch auf spotify
als
prostituierte
corolla und wirklich auch wirklich sehr
schön formuliert und einfach formuliert
dass man es sehr schnell versteht habe
ich das gefühl es gibt viele begriffe
zum beispiel das auf
das jahr abgekürzt mitesser und wenn ich
in kommentaren zum beispiel lese dann
sind aus begriffe die ich ja auch
erstmal nicht kenne oder verstehe weil
ich mich mit dem thema habe ich
auseinandergesetzt bezeichnet mal dieses
wort also was ist damit gemeint
es gibt erst mal die gesellschaftliche
definition darf der wand geredet hat
passt ja erst mal leute die uns im kampf
von nicht irgendwie türkisch aussehende
leute
wenn man das geografisch aber war
wörtlich nimmt dann heißt das eigentlich
was ein asiate jemand aus asien ist
wollen wir sind es ein riesiger
kontinent das ist ein kontinent rote
krawatte dabei ist woraus nicht dabei so
indien dabei dass ich denen alle anders
aus und die machen die nach auch andere
erfahrungen und deswegen finde ich es
sinnvoller wenn wir oder wenn ich meinen
videos dann sage gilt als die trasse
weil das halt dort genau die ecke
beschreibt wo ich oder wo meine wurzeln
liegen und es geht auch einfach mehr mit
phänotypen also sieht man aus und wir
seit man sofort an dass wir eben ein
asiatisch sind oder das was man eben
mutter asiatische meint wenn man sagt
ihr habt ihr die erfahrung jetzt vor
einigen jahren gemacht glaubt es gibt
eine tendenz der besserung also ich weiß
ich weiß
dass man ja die diese lieder nicht mehr
singen oder oder dass es aus vielen
kindergärten raus gepackt wurde jetzt in
einer erwachsenenwelt merklich ist schon
dass auf jeden fall viel mehr leute
darauf bedacht sind eben aufzupassen
okay was sage ich oder wenn ich was
falsches sagen dann entschuldige ich
mich kurz und wir gehen einfach weiter
man muss viel das sagen wir auch nicht
ausdiskutieren aber es wird ja meistens
dann auch ein fass aufgemacht von weißen
menschen bei fidelity das ist auch ein
begriff den ich gerade erst mal durch
gelernt habt warum ist white facility
eigentlich so gefährlich bzw so
unpassend ich habe diese stadien genauso
durchlebt ich habe deinen tik tok
gesehen mein erster gedanke war ich bin
doch eigentlich rassistisch und war doch
gar nicht so gemeint ich hab mich aber
gleichzeitig total geschrieben für
diesen kritiken beigebrachten der schule
und im kindergarten zwei kameras sollen
das wasser ist etwas schlechtes sind und
leute umbringen und so natürlich wir
wollen uns nicht damit assoziieren und
da kommt dieses beispiel charity
endspiel weil sein selbstbild und das
bild passte von rassisten hast das passt
nicht zusammen dann schließlich halt
erstmal angegriffen als weiße personen
oder als eine person die dafür zur rede
gestellt wird wegen rassismus damit will
ich auch sagen dass ja auch nicht was
sie kennen das charity zeigen weil wir
halt in diesem weißen system aufwachsen
aber da begriff
immer dieses bild von rassisten im kopf
ohne gott da ist jemand der leute
einfach auf der straße als beleidigt und
so aber rassismus fängt ja auch schon
ganz woanders an also micro aggressionen
auch schon also alleine wenn du mich
jetzt fragst ok wo kommst du her und ich
sag dir ich komme aus nrw und dann
fragst du nochmal nach wo kommst du denn
wirklich hat das ist immer so diese
typische frage und das heißt er stand
okay du akzeptierst mich nicht als
deutsche person verbrennt es nicht
eigentlich du siehst okay mein phänotyp
sind nicht aus wie du und
dementsprechend kann ich gar nicht
deutschland ja dieses charity ich glaube
das ist eine abwehrhaltung auch deswegen
sind sagt lesen sich und das ist sehr
sehr gefährlich die zweite charity das
war für rassismus betroffene hat es dann
erstmal die auswirkungen dass wir auch
anfangen unsere erfahrungen anzuzweifeln
also hatte ich auch früher freunde
gehabt wie wie dich die dann solche
späße gemacht haben sie vielleicht um
eine wie ich
will
die dann sie sich nur bei der
akzeptierte ich mache mir da so anderen
sage ich erst mal ja das was rassistisch
deshalb weh getan und dann abends mit
defensive haltung weil sie wollen nicht
mit dem rassisten assoziiert werden und
dann fangen wir an gegen nicht zu obwohl
sich die armen gemacht haben aber darum
geht es nicht sondern die wahrheit hat
ein anderes bild als ich dass ich als
minderheit bin dann die über sensible
personen und dann gehe ich nach hause
und fangen an meinen erfahrungen und
anleihen die viel zu zweifeln und rede
dann das nächste mal nicht mehr darüber
was würdest du sollst dein ziel nennen
was du mit deinem content erreichen
möchtest zuerst wollte ich mittags gibt
es
das hat sich da irgendwie gewendet weil
ich bemerkt habe dass man mit einem
trick algorithmus leicht leute erreichen
kann mein ziel ist dass wir mehr
gespräche und asiaten haben weil ganz
ehrlich die echten community damit
weitere spezielle ist die station
community wir sind sprach wir haben
nicht genug austausch und wir müssen
lauter werden und mein ziel ist halt
andere zu zeigen setzt euch eins steht
für ich selber ein oder andere dazu zu
bringen sich zu reflektieren ich möchte
dass wir mehr solidarität mehr
miteinander zeigen auch also du hast auf
jeden fall eine sehr starke direkte art
die glaube ich an hacken kann aber
vielleicht liegt es auch nur daran dass
viele einfach auch um informiert sind
und wofür du litti sich gleich
angegriffen fühlen nur weil vielleicht
mal etwas aufgezeigt wird da sie nicht
dem selbstbild in neun stadien bin ich
dann da durchgegangen und irgendwann
habe ich auch mal geweint und dachten
bisher aber das kann doch gar nicht sein
ist die ganze welt ist gegen mich ist
und irgendwann kam ich weiß gar nicht
wann das war irgendwann kam so ein
moment wo ich dachte man also stoppt so
es geht nicht gerade um mich und ab hier
darauf vorbereitet haben und ich gedacht
habe so kind was spreche ich jetzt an
spreche ich jetzt diesen kommentare an
die ja auch untereinander stattgefunden
haben jetzt gar nicht speziell gegen
mich oder gegen das ging ja so in alle
richtungen da merkt man ja wie hitzig
auch dieses thema ist das irgendwie alle
meinen irgendwen verteidigen zu wollen
ein großer unterschied ist ja die einen
sind informiert die anderen glaube ich
nicht so ja wenn man mich dann lob dafür
dass ich eine entschuldigung mache sie
meist eher nicht böse sie wollen wir
irgendwie ihren support zeigen aber es
deshalb glaube ich durch diese
uninformiertheit einfach nicht gerade
der platz die familien in der ddr
schreibt nicht toll dass du da mal drauf
oder irgendwie aber nicht so dieses
statement runter selbst gerade mit
diesem video also wie ihr schreibt jetzt
runter dass ich jetzt was ganz tolles
gemacht habe weil es ist irgendwo
selbstverständlich natürlich jetzt ist
es gut dass wir das machen aber ich bin
jetzt keine heilige deswegen also
wirklich bitte spart euch irgendwie
fiese kommentare wenn ihr anderer
meinung sei last vielleicht auch dieses
video dann einfach erstmal ein bisschen
sacken ich glaube die meisten leute
meint sowas nicht böse auch wenn du
fragst ok wo kommst du eigentlich her
ich das ist nicht böse gemeint ich weiß
selber dass man dass ich besser meint
man muss aber immer wieder daran denken
was ist wichtiger ist die intention
wichtiger oder ist wirklich das was dann
die konsequenz ist daraus wichtiger das
hat eine stärkere auswirkung auf mich
und das ist wichtiger als seine
intention für deine gefühle auch genannt
wurden richtig wieder da wird dann oft
argumentiert wird aber ich bin auch
neugierig wo die person hat fand ich
verstehe die neugier jungen wo also aber
die kann man dann auch erst mal für sich
lassen nicht jeder ist mit seiner kultur
verbunden wie schon erwähnt deswegen
geht auch jeder anders mit erfahrung und
wollen dann auch antworten dass sie
deutschland weil auch hier geboren und
aufgewachsen sie sich als deutsche
identifizieren wollte ich das nochmal
und wenn man trotzdem wissen will wo die
wurzeln liegen dann einfach abwarten
weil wenn die person mit ihrer kultur
verbunden ist die wird irgendwann
erzählen das habe ich das erfahrung erst
mal also ich frage mich auch immer muss
man das wirklich beim ersten mal
wirklich wissen dass ganzes ergeben im
gespräch wenn du wirklich später erzählt
gibt da so ein ganz gutes bild wenn man
fast dass moss pyramide eingibt oder
meisten programme gezeigt haben sind
spitze so ein eisberg im wasser
über der wasseroberfläche ist dann die
spitze wo dann so da steht dann das der
leitung gebracht werden oder sogar
aggressive sagen dass man als rassismus
versteht dass jeder unter wasser ist
muss verstehe ich aber alles unter der
wasseroberfläche dass deshalb auch
rassismus weil das existiert existiert
auch das was über der wasseroberfläche
ist das rekordhalter happy end ist was
rassismus ist wer da nur die spitze und
hätten dann ist dann alles unter dem
wasser das ja viel mehr ja was soll
internet klar es bringt uns nicht um das
hat gravierende auswirkungen auf unsere
realität auf unser selbstbewusstsein auf
unsere identität an schwarz weißen erst
mal politische begriffe sind auch dass
es so dass statt bevor man über
rassismus rede da sind viele leute
beratungsverträge nicht mal wissen was
das bedeutet weiß was bedeutet sparen
genauer von hautton her sind wir uns
schon ziemlich ähnlich und bei dem
begriff mit schwarzem weiß geht sind
überhaupt nicht umhaut fahren sondern
einfach um die politische wende
politisch gesehen werden ich musste mich
irgendwie auch erstmal damit ein freund
okay ich gehöre als politisch zu der
gruppe ich bin weiß ich werde zu den bei
horses realisiert dass du weißt bewusst
nicht durch das buch ja also ich habe
polnischer eltern und die kommen die
sind für 30 40 jahren nach deutschland
gekommen und ich bin hier aufgewachsen
und geboren hatte aber auch in der
schulzeit natürlich diese typischen
polen witze und passt auch wenn das
bakom hat seine federn zu sie klaut um
etwas daraus deswegen kann ich so einige
sachen auch nachvollziehen ich brauche
italienische blut deswegen haben wir
dann sehr haarig und hatte dunkle augen
dunkle haare ja ich hatte irgendwie
schon früher man so ein bild wie weißen
waren für mich immer die blonden also
die ja irgendwie auch richtig deutschen
aber ich bin auch weil das geld für den
weißen da kommen wir zudem konnte hatte
ich viele weiße auslandes schulfreunde
die dann halt mit mir sozusagen
sympathien war in dem die gesagt haben
ja wo ich bin auch ausländer oder die
wahl mit ihr mitfühlen mit dem rassismus
und dann möchte ich ein begriff erklären
das heißt jene phobie das bedeutet
einfach fremd gefälligkeit und das ist
in deutschland natürlich ein großes
problem weil ist es nicht so dass
deutschland von frankreich jetzt eine
gute geschichte hast du damit polen oder
mit keine ahnung vom europäischen
untereinander alle gras und dann wird
wieder geliebt rassismus gegen weiße von
anderen weißen meinen dass
fremdenfeindlichkeit ich mal wenn die
jetzt dich als wurde diskriminiert oder
als italiener wenn oder keine ahnung
dann geht es ja um deine herkunft und
bei asiaten oder ja oft dass asiaten
oder wenn man dieses spaß zu
diskriminiert dann ist das ding scheiß
egal wo die herkommen die gruppierung
ich finde es auf jeden fall mehr gut
dass ihr euch dafür einsetzt weil ich
glaube es kann auch hart sein sich aus
der masse dann vielleicht auch raus zu
stellen auch wenn viele leute sich nicht
bereit fühlen sich dem thema zu stellen
und sagen ach das ist doch gar kein
problem in deutschland wir haben auch
hier ganz andere probleme hatte ich bin
auf jeden fall megastadt von euch dass
ihr da auch ja so stellung bezieht ich
glaube wäre es echt schön wenn euch
viele folgen und ich glaube umso lauter
man ist umso mehr hinzu dass eindeutig
mir vorgeworfen haben dass ich den
keller ging dicht gemacht haben
abzugeben das finde ich das mal böse
wenn ihre anti rassismus arbeit von
anderen asiaten hören wollt dann folgt
anderen asiaten ich bin nicht die
einzige stimme im internet und ich finds
halt wichtig und ich hoffe das ist auch
viele mitte nehmen dass daraus lernen
kann und es ist dann ein teil verliert
das hast du gemacht und ich werde mich
jetzt niemals darstellen sagen ich war
noch nie rassistisch und also das
sowieso nicht und wie du ja auch gesagt
dass jeder ist irgendwo ich finds halt
sehr wichtig dass man sich nicht davor
drückt nur weils und das gefühl
unangenehm ist sich mit sich selber zu
beschäftigen so habt ihr vielleicht noch
mal wie exit weißen noch podcast oder
hörbücher oder irgendwas was wohl hier
sagt hey da kann man sich auch einfach
noch mal informieren und krieg
vielleicht einfach noch mal neues bild
auf die ganze sache also vielleicht auch
gerade anti asiatischer das ist muss
aber ich kenne drei von klein auf
nachdem glaube ich auch im pott kann
finde ich ganz ganz gut kann ich auf
jeden fall empfehlen kooperation
kommunikation genau und das ich
einsetzen des bitkom sollten germany
noch also ich verlinke die alle auch in
der
korea und das ist ja so ein thema nummer
drei gewesen ja bei dem southeast asian
akzente nicht nachgemacht das habe ich
sofort verstanden erstens wie sollen wir
das macht zweitens warum laden wir das
noch hoch und sagen sogar noch das ist
racing bei dem anderen thema durch asian
vettel fette schalding betrieben habe
dann habe ich nicht so schnell gesehen
ich heute auch anders weil für mich
bastian super kompliment haye ist doch
ganz toll das wird ein sehr schöner ich
habe angefangen
abzuhören kate waren gucke ich mir auf
netflix an ich gehe zum kurieren
barbecue ich liebe das alles ich finde
es irgendwie gibt mir das alles ein
gutes gefühl das ist ja in ordnung oder
also trend wenn man so ein interesse an
der an dem ganzen hat also überhaupt ich
würde es auch tun denn ich habe
interesse am popkulturellen ja also das
finde ich auch besser als man sollte ich
mir den asiatischen kultur interessiert
wenn es nur hopp oder dann sagt doch du
bist ein popkultur ist hört ja so was
ist eigentlich da drauf ich mag ich
hatte es auch an es ist eine coole
musikrichtung auf jeden fall aber das
hat nicht unbedingt was mit asiatische
kultur zu tun oder koreanischer kultur
und ich würde auch super gerne mal nach
südkorea reisen aber jetzt nicht
irgendwie mehr tempel anzuschauen
sondern um katie zu kaufen koreanische
essen zu gehen frechen konzert zu
besuchen so das ist aber in ordnung oder
wenn man dieses interesse einfach auch
daran hat es oft in pulow natürlich
erstmal lachen ja du dir nur von korea
aus und es gibt von bild weiß gar nicht
wo ich das gesehen habe aber da was
leute denken wenn sie von asien sprechen
und zwar wirklich alle asiatischen
ländern gesperrt und man sieht nur noch
südkorea und japan und dann kann es aber
auch spezifizieren ich interessiere mich
für koreanische berühmten chor
genau ich habe dann eine frage an sich
hat sich über dein teekonsum dein bild
überall südostasiatische mehr agenda
natürlich aber das ist dann wie in
kempen gewesen oder war ein bild über
ostasiatische länder vor ort ich habe
das gefühl so wie ich aufgewachsen bin
waren asiatische männer irgendwie nie im
bereich des denkbaren wie ich in dem
täter her gesagt hat das war immer so
dieses schönheitsideal wanheimer unit
und backstreet boys und sowie seite ich
habe das sogar blöd formuliert und es
war einfach nur weh und ich finde es gut
dass du auch darüber redet wie
aufgewachsen ist mit welchen medien
gefallen aufgewachsen ist weil kommen
wir zu der präsentation ist es so
wichtig man hat zwei weitere
präsentation wie bist du mit der
ostasiatischen präsentation können also
was hat das für aus dem punkt für dich
gehabt das ostasiatische männer als
undenkbar erklärt worden sind naja also
sieht man ja schon in filmen serien wo
spielen die wild ostasiaten wird immer
den filmen wo sie eben der lustiger sind
der der undenkbare der erste freund der
hässliche professor oder so dann eben
auch dieser dieser akzent na einfach
ausgenutzt wird um damit eben lustig zu
sein und dann sehen dass junge leute
denken sich auch der im film macht es ja
auch komme ich mach das doch auch name
und das hat dann solche auswirkungen
aber da patrick mal gar nicht dran und
es hat so große auswirkungen auf uns auf
unsere kindheit jugend auf die jugend
von den kindern heutzutage und das ist
halt echt weitreichend ich weiß nicht
was auf sie traten heutzutage leben also
jetzt die höheren leute die noch zur
schule gehen ich würde das gerne westen
also wenn solche die das video anschaut
bitte kommentiert eure erfahrungen ich
möchte wirklich mehr austausch in der
gewöhnliche haben dass dieser wichtige
jetzt noch zum bild des ostasiatischen
man ist und dann sieht das also erst mal
wegen der verfehlten repräsentation und
dem stereotyp dass dieser als undenkbar
erklärt werden das hat bei mir auch die
auswirkungen gehabt dass während der
schulzeit drei waisenmädchen gesamt mich
angeschaut haben und dann gesagt haben
ich kann nicht mal sagen also gleich
auch in deutschland aufgewachsen bin
habe ich dann auch selber gedacht dass
wir da nicht attraktiv sein kann ich
habe dann an mir selber gezweifelt ich
muss das erst mal googeln keine
asiatische männer gut aussehen und ich
da auch noch auf männer steht und da
nicht mal auf solche ideen kann die
wirklich aussehen mein selbst hast war
wirklich da oben junge wegen korb weil
es dafür nicht das also einerseits finde
ich das ist das eine tolle sache ist es
hat sich gut an ich beispiel coop ist
die musik
ich finde ich dass man es bewusst
konsumieren muss weil das ist wir lieben
unseren im kapitalistischen system ist
muss man immer im hinterkopf behalten
und das kap im endeffekt auch wenn das
totale musikrichtung ist es ist eine
abgefragte musikindustrie wo capitole
die produkte verkauft werden das ding
ist wenn man von westlichen medien wo
also jahre erstmal als undenkbar
repräsentiert werden also erstmal dieser
rassistischer stereotype zu kommen
vielleicht nur noch käfer konsumiert wo
asiaten die tolle produkte verkauft
werden ich glaube da ist dann dass das
problem dass man eine anfänglich aus
asiatisch männer zu kritisieren weil man
dann auch anfängt die produkte zu
behandeln weil fängt dann nicht an aus
japan besser zu behandeln weil dieser
wechsel von den stereotypen asiaten als
unattraktiv oder asiaten als jude im
endeffekt die werden trotzdem gruppiert
und es werden stetig für auf die gelegt
und dann reflektieren was man konsumiert
dass wenn ich wichtig also jetzt auch
nicht nur auf körper bezogen sondern
allgemeinen medien was sinnbildlich auch
verkaufen welchen und ja die die
popindustrie leute das ist den scheiß
egal was was für auswirkungen jetzt das
hat's drauf osten also wir hatten in
westlichen ländern damit haben sie ja
nichts mehr zu tun die wollen nur sehen
wie die in korea geld machen ja klar ist
dann wirtschaftlich ein sport auch in
ansi korea das war natürlich sehr lange
und ausführlich beziehungsweise in
eingaben gerade aber auch schon
gesprochen dass es einfach noch viel
mehr zu dem thema zu sagen geben könnte
wie schließen wir das jetzt am besten
apfel was für ein abschluss wort finden
wir dass die leute vielleicht auch einen
guten gefühl rausgehen und sagen hey ich
habe etwas gelernt ich habe das gefühl
ich mache jetzt nicht noch mal die
gleichen fehler und bin wirklich
sensible arbeit auf mich über häppchen
informiert euch über weltfremd ist das
ganz wichtig weil diese zweite charity
wie schon erwähnt rassismus betroffenen
nicht hilft oder dazu führt dass diese
auch noch anfang an ihren erfahrungen zu
zweifeln da müssen dann auch rassismus
um betroffene reflektiert charity und
das erst mal ablegen weil nicht jeder
was ist was betroffen ist so stark wie
ich und setzt sich trotzdem weiterhin
dagegen einen auch beleuchtet sagen
übertreibst aber durch aufklärung und
durch recherche habe ich dann gelernt
nicht die weiter für mich einfach müssen
erstmal rassismus um betroffene das
lernen und auch was das betroffene
müssen weil ich ich hätte gerne als
rassismus betroffen new york das ganze
wissen gehabt damit ich mich wehren kann
aber es hat schon die elbe leute gesagt
haben du übertreibst das nächste mal
habe ich da meine fresse gehalten also
ich finde ganz wichtig wenn euch jemand
kommt also sagt hey das sind das was ist
das hier einfach zuhört und euch fragt
erst mal nicht gegen argumentiert
sondern euch wirklich mal fragten ok hat
diese person vielleicht recht ist da was
wahres dran einfach mal reflektiert und
das einfach nach hause nimmt
nacht überschläft und ja einfach mal
recherche betreiben schon gesagt wir
sind alle auf eine art und weise
rassistisch und das einzige was man
dagegen machen kann das einfach offen
sein crash er an sich bilden meinungen
anhören und vor allem als weiße personen
eben nicht gegen sani menschen und hier
rassismus erst als system verstehen als
system wo wir bei geboren werden und wo
wir auch so erzogen werden das ist
deswegen nicht zu hinterfragen weil es
halt eben system ist da schon seit
vielen jahrhunderten jahren existiert
deswegen macht das was nicht zum nazi
oder auf der sache sondern wir sind
anders
der ist nur die kleine spitze wiederum
renault ich finde ihr beide habt super
gemacht ich bedanke mich wirklich am
herzen dass ihr auch hergekommen seid
und da auch lust zu hattet und mir auch
einfach viel erklärt habt ja vielleicht
auch meinen zuschauern und vielleicht
sehen wir uns ja mal wieder klappt und
schreibt gerne etwas was ihr dazu denkt
was ihr für erfahrungen gemacht habe
vielleicht auch und seid bitte ned in
den kommentaren es geht hier nicht darum
jemanden an pranger zu stellen oder es
geht einfach nur um einen offenen
diskurs darüber und vielleicht dem einen
oder anderen einen neuen gedanken
einzupflanzen da vielleicht mal ganz
gutes ja auch wir sind zunächst mal
wieder biss dann
bei